So, Michael wants us to do a quiz.
Because Michael likes quizzes cause he thinks you like
quizzes. And so, I want you to answer
this question before Michael gets a chance to. So
just to be clear here's the question again. What happens to the distribution
over a particular example i when the hypothesis ht that was output by the
example. Agrees with the particular label, Y-sub-i.
Okay, so we have four possibilities when they agree.
One is the probability of you seeing that particular
example increases. That is, you increase the value of
D-sub-t on i. Or the probability of you seeing that
example decreases. That is, the number d of t
of i goes down, or it stays the same
when they agree or well it depends on exactly
what's going on with the old value of d and
alpha and all these other things. So ,you can't
really give just one of those other three answers.
So those are your possibilites. The other radio buttons
[LAUGH] only one of them is right. And go.